[موسيقى]
النباتيه هي فلسفه تحاول منح الحيوانات
حقوقنا اساسيه تحديدا حقهم في جسدهم وحقهم
في المحافظه على حياتهم في اساسها هي
طريقه تعبير واسلوب تفكير يسعى الى الحد
بقدر الامكان من استغلال واستخدام
الحيوانات
[موسيقى]
انا شخصيا لا اتفق معهم اعتقد انه من
الجيد ان ياكل الناس الديك الرومي لا باس
اذا كانوا يريدون ان ياكلوا ما يريدون اذا
لم يزعجهم ذلك فهو عالم حر
[موسيقى]
يستمر الانسان في خيانه هذه الحيوانات عن
طريق نزع ريشها بابشع طريقه
[موسيقى]
اطعام امر شخصي للغايه واعتقد انه عندما
نشعر الناس بالعار او مشاعر الذم بين
الافراد فهذا عاده يكون طريقا صعبا للغايه
لان ذلك يمكن ان يجلب معه الكثير من الغضب
وردود الفعل القويه جدا من مثلا الفيجان
فوبيا
[موسيقى]